the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today what we're gonna do is focus on
yet another cofactor that you get out of
your vitamin bottle and today we're
gonna be looking at vitamin b6 and
vitamin b6 is the cofactor that used
what you use whenever you want to
metabolize amino acids where do you get
amino acids we all eat proteins the
proteins get degraded to amino acids and
we can use the energy released and trap
that energy to do biosynthesis and we
use amino acids convert them into
central metabolism and use them to make
fats or or sugars depending on what the
environment is telling us we need to do
so let me introduce you to this cofactor
the vitamin itself as you have seen now
over and over again is not the actual
cofactor it's pyridoxal and so that's
what you eat out of the vitamin bottle
and as in the case of all vitamins
inside the cell it has to be converted
into the active form of the cofactor and
the cofactor we're going to be talking
about the active form is pyridoxal
phosphate which is called PLP and the
structure of paradox so there are two
main main structures of the pyridoxal
phosphate cofactor one of them is
involved in 80 percent of all the
chemistry and the one we're going to
talk about today uses both forms of the
cofactor that fits into central
metabolism I'll show you how that fits
in in a minute
so pyridoxal phosphate has this
structure you have a pyridine ring the
pKa of the pyridine ring is 65 so it may
or may not be protonated
and the key part of the cofactor or one
of the key parts of the cofactor is this
aldehyde so pyridoxal means that this is
an aldehyde the second form of the
cofactor is pyridoxamine so this
aldehyde is somehow and we'll show we'll
look at how this happens is converted
from this aldehyde into an amino group
and this is called PMP or pyridoxamine
phosphate now the other thing I wanted
to show you before we move on to look at
more details at pyridoxal phosphate is
while this is the form of the vitamin
you almost never see this form inside
the cell it is always bound in the
active site of the enzyme and it binds
in the active site of the enzyme so
here's your enzyme through the epsilon
amino group of a lysine so you never
really when you purify the protein
you never isolate the aldehyde you have
so this is the aldehyde and I won't draw
out all the rest of the structure but
what you have is an amino group that's
attached to lysine in the active site of
your enzyme and what we're gonna do is
convert this ketone into any amine so
this is chemistry you see over and over
and over again you've seen it already
with carbonyl chemistry with
carbon-carbon bond forming reactions
with peptide bond hydrolysis that we've
already talked about but what you do is
you're going to convert this this
aldehyde into an amine you need to go
through a tetrahedral intermediate and
the carbonyl is polarized Delta plus
Delta minus you spent a lot of time
practicing this kind of chemistry to
form a tetrahedral intermediate and I'm
going to have a proton transfer so one
of the things that's tricky about this
chemistry is that if you count the
number of protons they move around a lot
in the active site and the fact is that
you want to protonate some
thing to make it into a better leaving
group you want a deep pro need something
to make it function more like a
nucleophile or as a base and nature is
figured out how to orchestrate all the
residues in the active site to do this
in most cases we don't understand all of
the details and so I'm not going to
focus on proton transfer but you're
going to see many proton transfers
within the active site so this gives us
a tetrahedral intermediate or transition
state you've seen that over and over
again and now what will happen is that
you want to lose a molecule of water so
again you need to protonate that and
what you form then is a new carbon
doubly bonded to a nitrogen
rather than doubly bonded to the oxygen
that's covalently bound to the enzyme
and so this is called an amine and
because it's an amine of an aldehyde
it's called an aldimine so whenever you
isolate your enzyme whenever you isolate
your enzyme the pyridoxal is always
covalently bound ok so this bond is is
chemically easy to hydrolyze but it's
always covalently bound ok so what I
want to do now is make a few
generalizations about pyridoxal but the
first thing is that in all cases
whenever you metabolize I want to
metabolize an amino acid pyridoxal
phosphate requiring enzyme is going to
be the key player ok
so here's an amino acid okay here's the
Alpha position the beta position and the
gamma position well what's a mate so
amazing and I remember first hearing
about this is that you can do chemistry
at all these positions and the way
nature figures out how to do this is by
orchestrating the active site with acid
base catalyzed
cat catalyst sitting around in the right
place to allow you to do the chemical
transformation that this protein has a
while
to do so let me just show you at the
Alpha position so this is the output
position you can cleave this bond I'll
show you how this happens you can alert
you can do all this chemistry with a few
simple chemical transformations takes
practice but once you sort of get what
these transformations are you can it's
amazing what you can get this cofactor
to help you do and I'll explain that in
a minute so you get cleavage of the
carbon-carbon bond that's losses C or
two that's a decarboxylation reaction we
don't talk about that in 507 but that
generates all of our neuro that kind of
reaction generates all of our
neurotransmitters you're going to cleave
this carbon hydrogen bond remember amino
acids are in the S configuration but for
example in cell wall of bacteria they
can be either the S or the arc
configuration so you can cleave that
bond and put the proton back on the
other face that's a Rasmussen reaction
you can cleave this carbon-carbon bond
between the Alpha and the beta position
that's a reaction remember we talked
about carbon-carbon bond formation this
is a reverse aldol reaction and the one
we're going to focus on today which is
the one that fits best into central
metabolism is what happens to this
carbon nitrogen bond so we have an amino
group of our amino acid is going to get
converted into a ketone group okay so
this group is going to get converted
into this group and to do that we're
going to use the amine of pyridoxal
phosphate that we have in the active
site of the enzyme so this is sort of
like a carbonyl and that's going to get
converted into the amine the
pyridoxamine so these are the two forms
of the cofactor so what I was going to
be focusing on is how these two how this
reaction actually happens and this is
the most complicated of all the
pyridoxal phosphate dependent reactions
so that i'm going to come back to this
in a minute
but what I want to do is make a few
generalizations about where you're going
to see pyridoxal phosphate chemistry in
primary metabolism so what we're gonna
see is the TCA cycle tricarboxylic acid
cycle of the krebs cycle plays a central
role it's found in the mitochondria
you're gonna see this over and over
again over the course of the semester
things feed in and out of the cycle a
cycle means it goes around and around
and if you remove something from the
cycle and don't put anything back into
the cycle the cycle stops and you're in
serious trouble so one way one thing one
way to feed in and out of this cycle is
through amino acids so this reaction
which we're going to call a
transamination or a transamination is
metabolism of amino acid
we'll see into an alpha keto acid so if
you look at the TCA cycle and we look at
this reaction what you'll see is you
have this compound called alpha
ketoglutarate okay so alpha
ketoglutarate and that's gonna
interconvert with the amino acid and so
this ketone is going to be converted
into an amino group and so we're having
the amino group converted into a ketone
group and pyridoxal is going to be
converted into pyridoxamine
so we're going to have PLP converted
into PMP I'm going to show you how that
works if we move so if you feed in
glutamate from your diet it by this
pyridoxal phosphate dependent reaction
can feed into the Krebs cycle if you
want to make amino acids on the other
hand you can suck some of the alpha keto
acid out and convert it into amino acids
and you have to have a way of
controlling whether you feed in or you
actually remove your metabolites from
this cycle if you come up here and looks
at look at oxaloacetic acid an aspartic
acid so oxaloacetic acid is also an
alpha keto acid okay and the amino acid
Oh Oh can you see I probably get too
close to the edge okay and so here we
have the amino acid so here we have
amino acid alpha keto acid amino acid
alpha keto acid if you go further up and
go
pyruvate feeds into the TCA cycle
pyruvate comes from like electrolysis
pathway which again is breakdown of
sugars pyruvate is an alpha keto acid
this is a ch3 so this is the simplest
and this can get into converted into
Elleni so what you see is this same
theme amino group ketone amino group
ketone I'm being sloppy here most amino
groups are protonated because a PKA is
remember is around nine so they're
mostly protonated in solution I should
protonate this over here as well and so
you have a ketone group in amino group
so this is called an applaud the
antibiotic pathways where things can
feed in and feed out of central
metabolism and this is the only time
during the course of 507 that you're
introduced to amino acids and how
they're metabolize so what I want to do
now is then briefly show you how this
transformation actually works okay so
I'm gonna give you some general rules so
the transformation I just showed you an
alpha an amino acid into an alpha keto
acid looks to be complicated and I told
you the cofactor changes its structure
from an amine into an amino group and
the question is how does that happen so
I want to show you in a bunch of simple
basic rules that allow you to think
about all pyridoxal phosphate requiring
chemistry so I'm going to write down the
rules and then I'm going to show you how
it works on the reactions we were just
looking at this these transamination or
transamination reactions so how do we
think about the mechanism of these PLP
enzymes so the first thing is the first
step
is so you're gonna start out with an
amine bound to the active site if your
pyridoxal phosphate and an amino acid
I'll abbreviate it AAA and the first
thing you do is you're gonna remove this
amine and form a new amine with the
amino acid so that's called a trans
emanation reaction okay so what we're
gonna do is form a new amine and so the
amine from the amino acid and I'll show
you how this happen is going to take
switch with this one and so what you're
left with in the active site is the
amino group of the lysine okay so this
lysine Nature has figured out how to
minimize the numbers of acid and base
groups constrained in the region the
active site where all the chemistry
happens and she uses this lysine which
initially is holding covalently the
cofactor in the active site she then
uses this lysine to do general acid
general base catalysis and she uses it
over and over and over again now every
pyridoxal enzyme is distinct and has
additional groups in the active site so
but we know a lot about this chemistry
we even know what the groups are but
we're gonna look and talk about
generalizations so the first thing we
have to do is we need to free up our
general acid base catalysis
covalently bind the amino acid which is
a substrate into pyridoxal so that's the
first step and i'm going to come back to
this in a minute the second step in all
of these reactions is all amino acids
have an alpha hydrogen okay that alpha
hydrogen has very high PKA it's very
hard for a normal amino acid side chain
in the active site to remove that proton
because it's not acidic enough so what
I'm going to show you is
pyridoxal increases the acidity of that
alpha hydrogen making it easier to do
the chemistry so the second step in
almost all pyridoxal reactions is
removal of the alpha hydrogen and we can
do that because PLP makes the hydrogen
more acidic and I'll show you why that's
true in a minute and then the third
thing is once you remove that hydrogen
then you've got to look at the chemistry
you want to catalyze and we're going to
be talking about this transamination
transamination reactions but remember I
told you can do all this chemistry at
Alpha Beta Gamma so you need to assess
what the substrate is and what the
product is and then within the active
site you're gonna have to do a lot of
manipulation with acid and base
catalysts to get you into the final
stage where you can release the product
you want to release so the last step in
this reaction in all pyridoxal reactions
so we do some chemistry in here okay and
I'll show you what the chemistry is with
trans amination reactions there were
trans emanation reactions now I keep
saying
trans amination and trans emanation
that's because most textbooks call it
transamination because they think about
pyridoxal as the aldehyde but reality
pyridoxal is always in the amine
covalently bound and so that's why it's
a trans emanation rather than a trans
amination so the last step then is
hydrolysis and I'll show you how that
happens or trans emanation to reform
this structure so we get ourselves back
to where we start so there's three
simple steps and in the middle depending
on what the reaction is you have to do
additional manipulations but all
pyridoxal enzymes go through these three
general steps the first step I told you
in all these reactions is trans
emanation okay so here's
our ship space and it's your pyridoxal
is covalently bound to the lysine in the
active site now one thing that students
often find confusing is the protonation
state of this amine and that's because
it's right around neutral pH pH 7 so
depending on what's in the active site
it could be protonated or not protonated
if it's protonated of course it can't
Kansas's reactivity for nucleophilic
attack so you wanted to be protonated so
the active site is going to manipulate
itself to put it in the protonated state
so here you have an amino acid okay and
here we have a protonated amine and so
this is a nucleophile and it can attack
the carbon of the amine to form a
tetrahedral addict so that's what we're
doing here so this is going to attack
this to form this tetrahedral antic and
you've seen again the tetrahedral
chemistry over again when I showed you
how you form this you mean in the first
place so tetrahedral chemistry
tetrahedral intermediates transition
states which collapse to form back in
means or carbonyls is happen to over and
over and over again and pyridoxal
chemistry so now what happens is we have
this tetrahedral intermediate or
transition state I have it in
parenthesis because it's a high-energy
intermediate it doesn't sit around and
let us look at it most of the time you
can never see it it's very high on a
reaction coordinate this collapses then
and when it collapses what do you
generate you generate the lysine and the
active site
okay so now we have generated a resident
in the active site that can function as
a general acid or general base catalysis
through the rest of the chemical
transformations and what have we done is
we've converted this mu mean with lysine
now to an amine of the amino acid so
that's what trans emanation is one you
mean to another amine the amine that's
covalently bound to the protein through
pyridoxal to an amino acid amine okay so
that's the first step
the second step is that ultimately and
almost all pyridoxal reactions you want
to remove this alpha hydrogen and that
alpha hydrogen again is extremely non
acidic but by complexing the amino acid
to pyridoxal this is what the function
of the cofactor is you are enhancing the
acidity of this alpha hydrogen you're
making it easier for a group in the
active site a general base catalyst like
lysine can now pull off this proton to
generate this intermediate okay now why
is this hydrogen more acidic well if you
look at the structure you can draw all
kinds of resonance structures which
shows that this carbon ion is more
stabilized because it's attached to the
pyridoxal cofactor so if you look at
this you can draw this resonance
structure which is shown here and you
can draw 20 other resonance structures
okay so the key here is you can remove
the alpha hydrogen because you're able
to delocalized this unpaired these
unpaired electrons on this carbon over
the entire system so let me show you
what that looks like so if I draw this
is called Donathan hypothesis so here's
our pyridine ring okay here's our you
mean and here's our amino acid here's
the carboxy as a sidechain and our group
and here's the carboxylate okay so the
idea is you have like a benzene ring if
you haven't seen pyridine rings but you
have a PI cloud that D localizes where
these electrons are completely
delocalized over the aromatic ring but
here you also have a PI cloud and these
things are close close close enough so
you can delocalized now what you're
going to do and the way nature decides
what chemistry can happen is since we
want to cleave in this case the carbon
hydrogen bond she places that carbon
hydrogen bond by
complexing the carboxylate and
complexing whatever the our group is she
places that carbon hydrogen bond
perpendicular to this plane of the pi
aldimine system so what you're doing
then is the lysine that we just
liberated from doing the trance
emanation reaction you now generate an
empty p orbital with unpaired electrons
in it generate the carbon ion and now
this system can completely be localized
so again this is point this pyridine
ring is planar so you can keep
completely delocalized the electrons
over this whole system this is a PI
cloud and now this is already set up so
that it can be localized over this whole
system so what you've done then is
because of the ability to stabilize this
carbon ion you're making that hydrogen
more acidic so if you wanted to say for
example cleave remember I told you at
the very beginning you might be able to
decarboxylate that enzyme would place
that co2 perpendicular to the plane of
the PI aldimine system and use the same
strategy to stabilize the resulting
carbon ion intermediate
we're not going to talk about that
chemistry and 507 so what you've done
then what the beauty of pyridoxal is
that she's increases acidity and allows
you a great deal of flexibility because
once you generate that carbon I and
those of you who've had 5:13 you'll
immediately recognize if you have a
leaving group on a carbon adjacent to
this carbon you can do an elimination
reaction so it sets up a whole series of
transformations but today we're only
focusing on the trans emanation reaction
how do we convert this to an alpha keto
acid okay and the pyridoxal to
pyridoxamine that's the question we're
asking so we do this chemistry and now
what we need to do we can use this
resonant
structure we want to ask the question
what is the product well we want to get
to an alpha keto acid okay and if you
look at this structure this molecule is
an amine of an alpha keto acid so this
is exactly the state we want to be in
but then we have all of this we have
this reactive intermediate here so what
we want to do is protonate someplace
here to generate this state so that the
last step in all pyridoxal reactions is
hydrolysis and now we're set up with a
hydrolysis reaction to generate the
alpha keto acid so we then want to ask
the question where could we protonate
and so again we have this lysine which
we now have used to pull off the alpha
hydrogen it's now protonated so now
instead of being a general base catalyst
here it's functioning as a general now
said catalyst and so now what can happen
is you can pick up a proton from this
lysine it's applying it with that proton
to generate this structure and
regenerate lysine as a general that can
function now is a general base catalyst
so it's toggling between general acid
and general base catalysis and now
remember what we want to get in the end
is this pyridoxamine and we want this
alpha keto acid and now we're set up to
rapidly go to an alpha keto acid where
have you seen chemistry like this before
you've seen it in the aldolase reaction
that we talked about with carbon-carbon
bond forming reactions so the last step
in all PLP dependent transamination is
hydrolysis so here we have the lysine
acting as a general base to activate
water for a nucleophilic attack on this
amine which is activated to have water
add and now you form again your
tetrahedral transition state I have all
of these unstable species and brackets
we really sometimes we see them
sometimes we don't but you have to work
hard to see them and now this simply the
tetrahedral ad ad collapses to form
pyridoxamine and forms the alpha keto
acid
so that's where we wanted to get but now
what happens is we're in the form of the
cofactor instead of being in the
aldehyde form we're in the amine form so
what we want to do now is reverse this
reaction using a different alpha keto
acid and we will generate a different
amino acid so now what can happen so in
their pyridoxamine form we then can bind
a different alpha keto acid remember in
the first slide I showed you three
different alpha keto acids like salad we
see the gas in alpha cute glitter ate
pyruvate you can reverse this whole
process and in the end what you end up
with is a different surgery you end up
with a different amino acid and you
regenerate your amine of pyridoxal so
out of all the only the only pyridoxal
phosphate requiring enzyme that goes
from the high or the amine to the
pyridoxamine of these transamination
reactions and so this is the most
complicated normally at the end of your
reaction you end up in this state and
this probably seems extremely confusing
to most of you but after you solve three
or four problems where you have to look
at the actual transformations and think
about this tetrahedral chemistry amines
and amino groups and alpha keto groups
you I think be able to actually easily
see how ingenious nature has been to
actually design pyridoxal phosphate and
I think the most amazing thing of course
is that pyridoxal phosphate without any
enzyme I told you you can catalyze many
many reactions you do all the reactions
at the end it doesn't spontaneously at
room temperature at pH 7 what the enzyme
does is only allows one of these
reactions by heavy having everything
positioned exactly the right way in the
active site so this is one of the
cofactors that I thought was amazingly
cool when I was in graduate school
made me want to become a biochemist